but when Joe Biden comes out choosing an  extremely extremely divisive issue and  one that is extremely unpopular I have  to wonder  why who whose vote he's trying to secure  by coming out and saying children should  get sex changes  I don't know whose vote he's trying to  secure but I will say that you know this  all it all goes back to the um  the Civil Right the Civil Rights era  legislation and so no matter what these  like small minorities do as long as they  couch it in civil rights language  they're never going to get beat no  matter what the vote says because it's  like enshrined and quote the  Constitution so they can say whatever  they want like it the voting population  won't matter it may like slow it or or  you know if if we object to it  temporarily but it's enshrined in law  that like if you count anything in you  know civil rights terminology that it's  going to stay like that